the map says this is highway six but the
people who live along it call it the
road of suffering for it links dozens of
communities in this devastated region
and thousands of residents who are
struggling to get by like the families
sheltering in this school it's an
official reception center for evacuees
who've lost their homes but the roofs
leak and everyone is hungry we are
starving here and we don't even have
plastic to keep us dry our homes are
already destroyed everything is gone in
classroom number three we found children
scraping the bottom of their pots their
parents have run out of porridge and the
government hasn't been here for days but
there are 200 people at the combatants
primary school and they need to be fed
have you had any donations we haven't
had anything we haven't had anything but
a porridge blankets no blankets nothing
we were told that the residents of one
village called moba had relocated under
a highway bridge and we found them just
down the road their pots were empty as
well and the villagers told me they
can't leave this place without
permission from the government secretary
you have to have permission to go to the
city but they have told us we have to
stay here and wait all this time yes she
said
obedience is obligatory in this top-down
centrally controlled nation even when
you're camping on a train line as we
traveled inland the floodwaters closed
in and we proceeded along a slither of
land on the roadside
hundreds of people were trying to feed
themselves using bamboo poles and
do-it-yourself hooks we stopped where
the cyclone had knocked out the highway
and discovered that Chinese engineers
have worked a temporary fix now
humanitarian aid can go by Road and the
man in charge was feeling good she'll
help you they feel happy you know aerial
means are very scarce so Dubai Road they
will manage for each much people it's a
big moment I can say yes a long line of
lorries were given permission to move
after ten days stuck on the roadside
it's a lifeline really the most
important Road in central mozambique and
it will change the way the aid agencies
deal with this crisis now they can put
their supplies in the back of trucks and
you can get a lot more in a lorry and
you can in a helicopter the flood waters
are receding but the suffering is real
and the people of Mozambique can wait no
longer John sparks Sky News Namit Under